Hola Esto es África 7 días en magazine
de la actualidad africana Mi nombre es
amalven offman comenzamos con los
titulares cerca de 400 personas han
muerto en el este de la República
democrática del Congo después de que
varias aldeas quedaron sumergidas por
Fuertes lluvias según los expertos en
meteorología estos fenómenos serán cada
vez más frecuentes como consecuencia del
cambio climático
Cuál es el papel de los antiguos
funcionarios del régimen del derrocado
presidente ciudadano
en la crisis actual mientras batios de
ellos anunciaron su fuga de la cárcel
intentamos descifrar la situación con
Jair experta en Sudán y fundadora del
centro de
pensamientory y hacemos un balance de la
libertad de prensa en el Continente la
organización de reporteros Sin fronteras
acaba de publicar un informe que
demuestra que el ejercicio de la
profesión de periodista en África sigue
siendo extremadamente complejo
es una de las peores catástrofes que ha
vivido este país en los últimos años
República democrática del Congo trata de
hacer frente a los enormes daños
causados por las intensas inundaciones
que han provocado la muerte de casi 400
personas y decenas de desaparecidos la
provincia oriental de kivu del sur es la
que fue afectada la región sufre
regularmente este tipo de fenómenos
durante la estación de lluvias entre
marzo y mayo según los expertos en
meteorología se prevé que su frecuencia
e intensidad aumenten con el cambio
climático esta catástrofe se produce dos
días después de que otras inundaciones
causaran también la muerte de al menos
131 personas en la vecina Ruanda en el
norte y el occidente del territorio
nuestra corresponsal en este país nos
cuenta más
se trata de una trajería Nacional para
la República democrática del Congo
además las ong presentes en el lugar
como la Cruz Roja existen en la
dimensión dramática de los eventos y
denuncian una cruel falta de medios para
atender a los supervivientes por ejemplo
el único hospital operativo de la zona
se enfrenta a la falta de medicinas
personal de enfermería y camas esta
catástrofe se produjo dos días después
que después de que una inundaciones
mataron al menos a 131 personas a la
oficina Ruanda allí podía hablar con los
habitantes que me contaron que tenía
miedo de una hambruna porque sus
cultivos también habían sido arrasados
tenemos hambre y miedo de que las aguas
nos maten y destruyan todo a su paso por
ejemplo ayer por la noche no vine aquí
para ver qué podía comprar gracias a la
ayuda de alguien pude comprar verduras
África Oriental una región muy sensible
al cambio de temperatura sufre
regularmente de inundaciones y de
corrimiento de tierra durante las
estaciones lluviosas según los
meteólogos se prevé que su intensidad y
frecuencia aumentan con el cambio
climático así lo confirmo el secretario
general de la ONU Antonio guteres quien
reaccionó a los eventos diciendo que se
trata de una nueva ilustración de la
aceleración del cambio climático y de
sus dramáticas consecuencias para los
países que no están Implicados En el
calentamiento global del planeta
cambiamos de tema en Sudán Qué papel
desempeñan los antiguos altos cargos del
régimen de Omar albahachir en el
conflicto entre las fuerzas armadas del
General
y las fuerzas de apoyo rápido el del
General a mohamedú pocos días después
del comienzo de los enfrentamientos
alrededor de 15 funcionarios del Antiguo
régimen consiguieron fugarse de la
prisión de cover situada al norte de la
capital jartum recordemos que Omar el
bachiller un presidente autocrático
perteneciente al movimiento islamista
gobernó Sudán durante más de 30 años
antes de ser derrocado en 2019 por un
levantamiento popular para hablar del
posible papel de sus partidarios en los
actuales acontecimientos estamos con
hulu Hayek especialista en Sudán y
fundadora del centro de pensamiento
sabemos algo de la huida de los antiguos
funcionarios del régimen de albahachir
no lo sabemos lo que sí sabemos es que
sean los islamistas detrás del conflicto
actual o simplemente Aprovechando que la
atención está en otra parte
probablemente asistiremos a un
resurgimiento islamista sabemos que han
intentado desde que al bachill fue
destitutado en 2019 volver al poder y
este conflicto presenta exactamente el
tipo de clima caótico en el que
prosperan y que piensan les permitirá
Volver al poder más rápidamente
y sabemos Qué papel pueden haber
desempeñado los islamistas en los
acontecimientos actuales
aún no lo sabemos porque en parte no
sabemos quién disparó el primer tiro lo
que sí sabemos es que ambas partes tanto
las fuerzas armadas sudanesas como las
fuerzas de apoyo rápido las fuerzas
paramilitares estaban muy bien
preparadas para este combate por eso en
los días y semanas previos al estallido
de este conflicto sabíamos que ambos
habían entrado en una fase de escalada
en la que era difícil hacerles
retroceder ahora bien Aún se desconoce
si los islamistas presionaron en parte
del lado de las fuerzas armadas
sudanesas para que así fuera o Si eso
fue incentivado por apoyos de las
fuerzas paramilitares pero es probable
que ambos pensaran que un enfrentamiento
abierto como este sería la mejor forma
de saldar viejas cuentas la dificultad
para los islamistas es que no pueden
volver después de un conflicto como este
con un enorme coste humanitario en
cierta medida tendrán que confiar en
elecciones Para volver con legitimidad
Así que probablemente no quieren
anunciar demasiado abiertamente su papel
en el apoyo a las fuerzas armadas
sudanesas y volvamos a este conflicto
entre los dos generales cuáles son sus
verdaderas intenciones
sinceramente es difícil saberlo lo que
Aparentemente quieren es el poder a toda
Costa quieren evitar que se les
responsabilice de los muchos crímenes
que han cometido no solo recientemente
no solo durante el periodo
revolucionario de 2018 y no solo en los
últimos 10 años más o menos sino desde
hace 20 años
donde ambos desempeñaron un papel
decisivo en el genocidio que tuvo lugar
allí Así que tienen una larga historia
de culpabilidad en la política sudanesa
pero también un gran interés en evitar
cualquier responsabilidad por ello
también no tienen gran parte de su poder
del hecho de tener tropas armadas por lo
que están muy interesados en evitar la
reforma de esas tropas porque quieren
seguir dirigiéndonos como lo hacen pero
ambos generales se enfrentan ahora a
muchos problemas de legitimidad
ninguno de ellos podría ganar realmente
porque Incluso si hay un vencedor
militar ha habido tal pérdida de
confianza pública por supuesto debido al
nivel de violencia y a la situación
humanitaria que ninguno de los dos
debería esperar realmente ser capaz de
tomar el control de un país como Sudán
Muchas gracias por este análisis
cambiamos de tema y abordamos ahora el
de la libertad de prensa en África el
último informe de reporteros Sin
fronteras hace un amargo balance de la
situación debido a los efectos entre
otros de la proliferación de las
noticias falsas y de la inseguridad que
asola varias regiones 84 periodistas de
trabajadores de los medios de
comunicación se encuentran actualmente
encarcelados la situación es
especialmente difícil en el norte de
África Egipto es el país con la mano más
dura con los periodistas 22
profesionales de los medios de
comunicación están actualmente en pero
también hay serias preocupaciones para
los periodistas que trabajan en el
sahell además de los riesgos que
plantean los terroristas las juntas que
han tomado el poder en Mali y burkina
faso ponen mucha presión sobre los
medios de comunicación en el mapa que
aparece en pantalla podemos ver que se A
qué se enfrentan los profesionales de la
prensa en África en Marruecos 20
periodistas han sido encarcelados desde
2018 y 13 siguen detenidos a día de hoy
en Egipto 115 han sido encarcelados
desde 2018 mientras que 22 permanecen
tras las rejas en Etiopía el número de
periodistas detenidos desde 2018 es de
48 y 12 lo siguen siendo hasta hoy en
República democrática del Congo 30
periodistas han sido encarcelados
durante estos últimos cinco años y tres
se encuentran todavía en prisión
y en somalia 37 periodistas han sido
puestos en cárcel desde el año 2018 y
tres siguen detenidos por haber ejercido
su deber de informar
vamos ahora a Kenia para hablar de las
mortíferas consecuencias del fanatismo
religioso forma que en sí pastor
autoproclamado comparece actualmente
ante el tribunal de la ciudad costera de
malindi está acusado de terrorismo por
causar la muerte de más de 100 personas
encontradas enterradas en un bosque del
sureste del país donde se reunían
miembros de su secta el espantoso caso
ha sido bautizado como la masacre del
Bosque de chacaola
desde el 13 de abril el bosque de
sacajola en Kenia se ha convertido en el
escenario criminal más famoso del país
al menos 110 cadáveres la mayoría de
niños han aparecido enterrados en una
treintena de fosas comunes eran
seguidores de una iglesia evangelista
dirigida por un pastor llamado Paul
mckenzi este pastor habría recomendado
víctimas ayunar hasta la muerte para
encontrarse con Jesús y fue detenido el
14 de abril se enfrenta a cargos que
incluyen asesinato y conspiración para
cometer asesinato en 2017 ya había sido
detenido por radicalización antes de ser
puesto en libertad tras pagar una fianza
aunque
sea mapa cuando me enteré de estas
muertes me quedé horrorizado pensé que
si hubiera permanecido más tiempo en esa
iglesia me habría ocurrido lo mismo pero
gracias a Dios mi familia y yo nos
fuimos a tiempo
pero más que en sí no es el único pastor
detrás de los crímenes el caso cobró
impulso el 27 de abril con la detención
del evangelista
Ezequiel odere director de otra iglesia
evangélica y también sospechoso de estar
relacionado con la muerte de sus
seguidores se le investiga por
radicalización y crímenes contra la
humanidad este escándalo ha reavivado el
debate sobre La regulación del culto
religioso en Kenia país
predominantemente cristiano el
presidente William rutto también
evangelista ha condenado los hechos
religion los terroristas utilizan la
religión para promover sus atroces actos
personas como el señor mackenzi utilizan
a la religión para ser exactamente lo
mismo
Kenia cuenta con más de 4.000 iglesias
evangélicas según cifras oficiales pero
todos los intentos anteriores de
regulación por parte de las autoridades
se han topado con una fuerte oposición
sobre todo en nombre de la libertad de
culto
y terminamos en senegal porque un joven
senegal es de 27 años se convirtió en el
primer fabricante de tablas de surf en
el país de África occidental los dejamos
con estas imágenes Gracias por
acompañarnos la actualidad internacional
continúa en France 24 y Francia 24.com
[Música]